♪
>> Sean: THE WOMEN'S MARCH
THAT WE WARPED YOU ABOUT
LAST WEEK, IT HAPPENED THIS
PAST WEEKEND AND WE SENT FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA CARTER
TO THE MARCH IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. WHERE THE ANTI-SEMITISM
SCANDAL HAS BEEN ROCKING THE
MARCH ORGANIZERS AND SARA
ASKED SOME OF THE PEOPLE AT
THE MARCH ABOUT THE
CONTROVERSY AND HERE'S WHAT
THEY TOLD HER.
>> TAMIKA MALORY AND LINDA
SARSOUR WHO ORGANIZED THIS
EVENT HAVE BEEN CREDIT YOU
SEED FOR ANTI-SEMITIC
STATEMENTS AND ALSO FOR THE
FACT THAT TAMIKA MALORY
WOULDN'T CONDEMN LOUIS
FARRAKHAN'S STATEMENT ABOUT
ISRAEL.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE HATE
SPEECH BY LOUIS FARRAKHAN
AND THEIR FAILURE TO CONDEMN
IT AND THEN BEING HERE
TODAY?
>> ONE WOMAN DOESN'T
REPRESENT ALL WOMEN.
SHE DOESN'T STAND FOR THE
ENTIRE MOVEMENT.
>> IRRELEVANT TO THE CAUSE.
NONE OF THE WOMEN HERE CARE
ABOUT THAT.
>> SOME MISTAKES WITHIN THE
LEADERSHIP DON'T DEFINE THE
WHOLE MOVEMENT AND THE
MOVEMENT AS A WHOLE STILL
HAS A LOT OF GOOD POINTS AND
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE.
>> DO YOU CONDEMN THOSE
ANTI-SEMITIC STATEMENTS.
>> OF COURSE.
OF COURSE.
100 PERCENT.
OF COURSE, OF COURSE.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT YOU
WOULD FIND EVERYBODY HERE
THAT THAT WOULD BE TRUE FOR
EVERYONE.
>> JEWISH I WILL SAY THAT US
SHOWING UP ISN'T IN SUPPORT
OF THOSE ANTI.
IT IS SUPPORT OF OURSELVES.
>> DO YOU CONDEMN TAMIKA
MALORY AND LINDA SARSOUR.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEY ARE LEADERS OF THIS
MOVEMENT.
AND I THINK THE LEADERS OF
THIS MOVEMENT ARE LOOKING TO
REACH GOALS.
AND THEY HAVE TO DO WHAT
THEY HAVE TO DO TO REACH
THEIR GOALS.
>> I THINK THE WOMEN'S MARCH
IS LARGER THAN THOSE TWO
INDIVIDUALS.
THEY DO NOT SPEAK FOR ALL
THE WOMEN HERE.
>> NO ONE SAID ANYTHING
TODAY ANTI-SEMITIC WE ARE
WORKING WITH HERE TODAY THE
NOW THE PRESIDENT.
>> BETTER TO BE A FEMINIST
THAN NO FEMINIST AT ALL.
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
ALTHOUGH ONE PERSON DOES
SOMETHING WRONG WE COME HERE
AND SHOW UP AND REPRESENT
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IN OUR
GOVERNMENT.
>> Sean: INTERESTING
OUTFITS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA
CARTER JOINS US NOW ALONG
WITH FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TAMMY BRUCE.
YOU THERE WERE IN ONE
CAPACITY.
SARA, WE WILL START WITH YOU
BECAUSE YOU WERE
INTERVIEWING THE PEOPLE AT
THAT PARTICULAR MARCH.
THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE A
LOT OF THEM ABOUT REAL
RADICAL ANTI-SEMITISM AND
YOU ALSO MENTION YOU HAD THE
THINGS THAT THEY HAD SAID.
WHAT ELSE DID YOU GLEAN OUT
OF THIS EXPERIENCE THAT WE
SENT YOU THROUGH?
[LAUGHTER]
>> I THINK IT WAS SHOCKING,
SEAN, FOR ME.
IT WAS REALLY DISTURBING
THAT A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT I SPOKE WITH DIDN'T
JUST TAKE A STEP BACK AND
SAY ABSOLUTELY.
WE CONDEMN IT.
IT'S COMPLETELY
ANTI-SEMITIC.
I BROUGHT OUT THE STATEMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY LOUIS
FARRAKHAN.
I ASKED THEM DIRECTLY DO YOU
CONDEMN THESE STATEMENTS?
AND SO MANY PEOPLE HAD SUCH
DIFFICULT TIME ACTUALLY
SAYING THAT THEY CONDEMNED
THE STATEMENTS.
THAT WHAT IS REALLY
DISTURBING.
ON THE OTHER HAND, A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE MARCHING.
SOME OF THEM DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON THE
WEEK PRIOR.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE CONTROVERSY WAS
ABOUT.
OTHERS JUST WANTED TO STAY
AWAY INTEREST IT ALL
TOGETHER.
AND SOME, SOME ON THE OTHER
HAND DID SAY THEY DID NOT
CON DOME IT.
THEY DID CONDEMN IT AND THEY
WERE SHOWING UP ANYWAY
BECAUSE PART OF THEIR CAUSE.
SOMETHING THEY WANTED TO BE
A PART OF.
DESPITE THE LEADERSHIP.
>> Sean: REFERRED TO
FARRAKHAN AS THE GREATEST
EVER.
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
ANTI-SEMITE IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
LET'S GO TO LINDA SARSOUR
ANOTHER ORGANIZER.
KNOWN TO PRAISE AND SUPPORT
SHARIA LAW.
SHE SAID I AM HER IS I ALLI
WHO WAS A VICTIM OF FEMALE
GENITAL MUTILATE A VICTIM.
SAYS SHE DOESN'T -- A WOMAN
DESERVE TO HAVE HER FEMALE
ANATOMY TAKEN AWAY.
WHEN SHE IS CONFRONTED ABOUT
IT SHE BLAMED THE JEWISH
MEDIA.
IT DOESN'T GET ANY MORE
ANTIWOMAN THAN THAT OR
ANTI-SEMITIC AND RACIST THAN
THAT.
>> MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OF
COURSE WAS EXTENSIVE.
SHE WAS BEING CONDEMNED
BECAUSE SHE WAS SPEAKING
HONESTLY ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
OF RADICAL ISLAM AND THAT IF
YOU CARE ABOUT WOMEN THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO BE HONEST
ABOUT.
WHAT'S INTERESTING CERTAINLY
ABOUT THE MARCH AND IT
SPEAKS TO, ALSO, I THINK THE
AMERICAN SENSIBILITY.
AMERICANS WANT TO GO OUT AND
HAVE AN IMPACT.
THAT'S CLEAR.
YOUNG PEOPLE, IT'S -- I WAS
DOING IT, OF COURSE.
IT'S WONDERFUL EXCITING
THING TO DO.
YOU WANT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THEY ARE
BEING USED BY A FRAUD.
THAT THEY ARE BEING USED BY
PEOPLE WHO SAY OH WE
UNDERSTAND.
THIS WE AGREE WITH YOU.
HERE'S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE DOING AND IT COMES WHEN
THEY WILL LOOK BACK AS I
HAVE DONE WITH SOME DEGREE
TO WITH MY LEFTIST ACTIVISM
IS YOU THINK ABOUT THE TIME
THAT WAS WASTED.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE DRIFTERS
AND THE FRAUD.
>> Sean: PART OF IT IS
WINSTON CHURCHILL INDUSTRY
IF YOU II  AND LIBERAL YOU
DON'T HAVE A HEART AND 40
AND LIBERAL YOU DON'T HAVE A
BRAIN.
>> IMMEDIATE NEWS FROM THE
WEEK BEFORE LET ALONE
HISTORICAL ANSWERS ABOUT HOW
WOMEN HAVE GOTTEN HERE.
WHAT WE ARE FACING NOW.
WHAT WE HAVE OVERCOME.
THE THINGS THAT UNITE US.
THAT'S WHAT THE FOCUS CAN BE
WHO WE ARE NOW.
>> Sean: YOU ARE FOUNDER.
>> INDEPENDENT WOMEN'S
VOICE.
IT WAS GREAT.
OUR MESSAGE WAS LOOK THERE
ARE PROBLEMS WE THAT WE HAVE
GOT OVERCOME.
IT'S THE 21ST CENTURY AND
TIME TO COME TOGETHER.
THE ARGUMENT AND THIS
RHETORIC ABOUT DIVIDING US
AND THAT THERE THERE IS AN
ENEMY AND EVERYTHING IS YOU
HAVE GOT TO GO EVER A PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO PUT KNEW A CAMP
OR HAND MAID'S TALE THAT'S
ARE A CHARACTER AND NOT
TRUE.
OUR MESSAGE WAS COMING
TOGETHER IS WHAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU GO TO A
WOMAN'S MARCH WHEN YOU HAVE
ONE OF THE ORGANIZERS THAT
SUPPORT SHARIA, WHICH THE
ABUSES WOMEN, KILLS GUYS AND
LESBIANS AND PERSECUTES
CHRISTIANS AND JEWS IN MANY
OF THESE COUNTRIES?
>> WELL, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, AND ESPECIALLY OUR
YOUTH, ARE BEING
DISENFRANCHISED BY
JOURNALISM TODAY.
THEY ARE NOT HEARING THE
TRUTH.
THEY ARE NOT HAVING ACCESS
TO THE TRUTH WE REALLY NEED
TO START EDUCATING
OURSELVES, SEAN.
THE ANTI-SEMITIC BEHAVIOR OF
THAT MIC CARKS MALORY AND
LINDA SARSOUR IS INCREDIBLE.
PEOPLE SHOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT UNFORTUNATELY, A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WENT AND
MARCHED.
THEY HAD NO IDEA WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH THEIR
LEADERSHIP THAT DAY.
THAT'S TRULY UNFORTUNATE.
>> MY QUICK ADDITION IS THE
LIBERALS WHO WENT BY OUR
MARCH, OUR RALLY WERE NICE.
THEY RECOGNIZED WE WERE
NICE.
THEY LIKED OUR SIGNS.
THEY EXPRESSED DISMAY IN THE
HOSTILITY OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STREET.
I THINK FOR CONSERVATIVES TO
REMEMBER.
BE OUT THERE, MEET PEOPLE.
DON'T LET THEM ISOLATE YOU.
>> Sean: IF I GO OUT THERE,
DO YOU REALLY WANT TO HANG
OUT WITH ME IF I'M OUT
THERE.